[Applause]
we are not adhering to every oscar
tradition tonight
but i am so happy that i now have the
honor to present the award
for best supporting actor
each of these five artists contributed
to the larger cultural conversation
through their storytelling this year
presenting us with themes of equity
and social justice in their own unique
and extraordinary ways
lakeith stanfield judas and the black
messiah
the keith with such power
you gave us an experience of what it is
when citizens are betrayed by their own
country
and while grappling with morality they
must fight to survive
daniel kaluya judas and the black
messiah
daniel hi
i just want to say thank you because
with your extraordinary commitment
and your endless research you did in
fact
beautifully get within the man and i
have been listening to you speak of
your inspiration in denzel washington's
performance in malcolm x
and just to say how grateful we are for
the inspiration you gave us
with not only the role but the words you
shared and the reminder
that you can't murder freedom thank you
to leslie odom jr one night in miami
leslie the gorgeous weight of
responsibility that you carried in these
discussions
in and around advancing social justice
it captured our hearts forever as did
your
chilling gift of bringing sam cook back
to us
thank you
to paul racy sound of metal
paul growing up as a hearing person with
deaf parents i know
you made such a tireless commitment
to expand the narrowed perspective
of deaf characters in film
and with this brilliant performance you
gave us the opportunity
to truly understand
what inclusivity means and we are so
lucky
thank you
and to sasha baron cohen the trial of
the chicago seven
sasha i
with your perfect portrayal of the
yippie iconoclast abby hoffman
you also imbued your own extraordinary
activist instincts
i was stunned i don't know if anybody
else was that you'd be attracted to
playing such a
disrupter it's so unlike you to rock the
boat but that's why they call it
act these are the nominees
for best actor in a supporting role
and the oscar goes to
daniel kaluuya
[Applause]
all right man
man thank you god
thank you god i can't be here without
your guidance and your protection
i think my mom thank you so much for
pouring into me
you gave me everything you gave me your
factory settings
so i can stand at my fullest height um
love to my sister a lot of my niece my
friends my family
everyone i love from london town to
kampala
like to thank my team incredible support
bro we out here yo
man man
it's good come on down ryan
zinzi serve proximity everyone at
proximity
charles king man everyone at macro
ron participant nigel everyone at warner
brothers thank you so much for
everything you poured into this
everything you pulled in this is so hard
to make a film
and make a film about a man like this
and and they made it possible they made
it happen
um i share this honor with um
uh the gift that is la keith stanfield
um
the light that is yeah yeah the light
that is dominique fishback
the incredible cast the incredible crew
you know i mean
lucas brothers are starting a journey
will bursting i see you
you know it's so incredible to look
around you to look around you and just
go
you're inspired by not only what they do
but who they are so that's amazing
chairman fred junior and mama akua thank
you so much for allowing us into your
life and into your story
thank you thank you for trusting us you
know with your truth
i appreciate you deeply and it's an
honor to to partner up and and
stand side by side with you and to
chairman fred hampton
bro man man what a man
what a man how blessed we are that we
lived in a lifetime where he existed
like thank you for your light
he's on this earth for 21 years 21 years
and he found a way to feed kids
breakfast educate kids
give free medical care against all the
odds
he showed he showed me he taught me him
up newton
bobby seal the black panther party they
showed me how to love myself
and with that love they overflowed into
the black community and to other
communities
and it showed us that the power of union
power of unity
that when they play divide and conquer
we say unite and ascend
thank you so much for showing me myself
and yeah man there's so much work to do
guys
and that's on everyone in this room this
ain't no single man job
that's i'm real and i look to everyone
every single one of you you've got work
to do
just say and i'm gonna get back to work
tuesday morning because tonight i'm
going up
we're going up you know what i mean
we're enjoying ourselves tonight because
we're celebrating
celebrate life man we're breathing we're
walking it's incredible it's incredible
like it's incredible my mom met my dad
they had sex
it's amazing like i'm saying i'm here so
i'm so happy to be alive so i'm going to
celebrate that tonight you understand
and i appreciate every single person in
the room appreciate everyone watching
our own you know
love peace love and onwards
we go again